g7 leaders meeting in southern germany
have agreed to invest hundreds of
billions of dollars in global
infrastructure the move aims to help
developing countries and counter china's
drive to exert influence in emerging
economies through large-scale
investments but it's russia's war in
ukraine that's dominating the three-day
meeting of the world's seven richest
democracies including the global
economic impact of moscow's invasion
they are meeting in the tranquil
surroundings of the bavarian alps
the top of the agenda is of course the
war in ukraine and the worldwide fallout
we've just tried to overcome a global
pandemic and it shook the global economy
and then as the global economy was just
recovering
russia's vicious attack on ukraine
happened
driving prices up
everywhere from food to energy
and casting deep uncertainty
especially in the most fragile countries
as host german chancellor olaf schultz
says the world is facing economic
difficulties just as big as the problems
of the 1970s when the g7 was starting
out
falling growth rates rising inflation
raw material shortages and supply chain
disruptions these are no small
challenges and we must share the
responsibility
u.s president joe biden announced a 600
billion dollar g7 initiative to boost
infrastructure in developing countries
with the aim of countering china's
growing global influence
but developing countries often lack the
essential infrastructure to help
navigate global shocks like a pandemic
so they feel the impacts more acutely
and they have a harder time recovering
in our deeply connected world
that's not just a humanitarian concern
it's an economic and a security concern
for all of us
tight security has so far prevented any
unrest at the summit but protesters have
gathered on the fringes
mainly climate change campaigners and
activists opposing germany's plans for a
big rise in defence spending
the leaders are considering more
measures to punish russia for the war in
ukraine the u.s canada japan and britain
have all announced a ban on imports of
russian gold the overall message is one
of unity in the face of aggression
let's cross over to our political
correspondent julia saldelli she's in
garmisch-potten near the summit venue
julia ukraine's president is expected to
address the g7 meeting there today are
the leaders gathered there united in
their approach to the war in ukraine
yes unity is the message that the
leaders here have been wanting to to
portray uh already yesterday but also
today when they're going to speak to
ukrainian president zielenski
they are united in criticizing russia
for its attack against ukraine which has
been defined as a brutal or uh
other similar adjectives that are have
been really critical against russia but
also in their support towards ukraine
and uh they are trying to shore the
support not only with words but also
with practical plans for example there
are discussions about possibly
implementing a ban on gold imports from
russia
gold imports that are a big source of
income from russia and are mostly
exported to g7 countries but also there
are talks about implementing a price cap
on
oil exports from russia and these are
all things that the leaders may want to
present to zelensky today and they
really want to show the ukrainian
president that the g7 countries are
there also in the long term
now helping the world deal with climate
change is another major topic for the g7
that's been the case in the past as well
how are the leaders there approaching
that
climate change has taken a bit of a back
seat now that the war in ukraine has
been the dominating topic at the g7 but
we shouldn't forget that climate change
is actually connected in some way to
russia's aggression in ukraine because a
lot of g7 countries now have the urgent
need to make themselves independent of
russian fossil fuels and they have to do
that quickly and it is an opportunity
for them to actually pursue uh faster
and bigger development of renewable
energies in in the future and that is
something that chancellor olaf schultz
also wants to bring home he has a plan
he has an idea to create a climate club
of willing countries who can be an
example and show leadership in terms of
building up renewable energy and
promoting sustainability and that is
something that is also really on the
minds of the protesters here at g7
climate has been one of the main topics
i spoke to many of them and they really
want the g7 to take concrete and fast
action in fighting climate change
julia thank you so much our
correspondent julia saudelli there in
garnish pardon care
for some more analysis let's bring in
stefan meister here he's head of the
program on international order and
democracy at the german council on
foreign relations stefan thanks for
being with us what do you make of the
proposals put forth by g7 leaders for
countering russian aggression in ukraine
and softening the economic fallout from
the war
i think we have reached a limit of
sanctions um from the from the western
side so now we are discussing gold uh i
think which which will have an impact on
the russian economy but as long as
russia still can sell sale oil and gas
globally as long as india and china and
other big countries are
buying russian gas and the russian even
the russian welfare fund is growing
i don't see that putin will will make
here any any compromise i think he will
not make any compromises anyway because
he wants ukraine to get under control
but i think i i think this is first of
all about unity this this summit but i i
don't think it will change uh russian
policy at the moment
the war in ukraine stefan is a defining
moment for the west which the g7
embodies to some degree how severely do
you see the west's influence in the
world being tested as a consequence of
this war
i think it is impressive how united
western countries are
g7 is somehow back yeah it was a it was
a declining format but i think western
democracies understand that they have to
coordinate and to cooperate more in the
light of the russian war at the same
time we can also see the limits we can
see that other countries like india like
china but also brazil south africa they
do not follow western countries on
sanctions
so we see a changing order
which is neither unipolan or bipolar
it's multipolar
and yeah and we can we can see that but
other major countries neither follow
russia nor follow the g7
you mentioned uh india and south africa
they're among a number of other
countries including indonesia and
senegal that have been invited to attend
the g7 this year
they are represented there what role are
those countries playing at that g7
i think g7 understand that they have to
engage with these countries
there is a growing axis or you can call
it between china and and russia as
authoritarian states uh and you have
countries like india which are
democracies but you also have other
countries who are
partly
democracies i think there is a growing
understanding that you have to engage
with major asian african and south
american countries as
g7 as western countries to um yeah to to
react to to challenges in in the global
world and that they need a place also on
the table to discuss major challenges
like the russian war in in ukraine and
the consequences of this war for global
economy and and food security
you said that you see a
multi-polar world emerging
where do you see
the the west particularly the united
states and europe has it their
importance been being is it being
diminished in this multi-polar world
that you see emerging
so it's the end of the u.s unipolar
world that means it is a decline also of
u.s power in global politics
europeans have to invest in in security
they have to become more independent
more more autonomous also on security
issues from the us who is not able and
willing anymore to to play the the
global police um
so you can say in the end this war
um strengthened g7 strengthen western
democracies in their cooperation but it
has shown also the limits of these
countries um and we can see that other
major players like china india indonesia
are becoming more important so you are
you can argue it's it's a diminishing of
western powers but at the same time if
they are united they are still strong
and they can make a difference
stefan thank you very much for talking
with us out with stephen meister from
the german council on foreign relations
here in berlin
thank you